let's say hello to some of the most  iconic performers in las vegas the blue  man group now let me tell you this i've  seen them before  live yeah incredible incredible they are  really amazing they've been around for a  very very long time i can't even imagine  how much paint they've gone through at  this point  all right but here they are now with  paint drums okay i'm ducking out of the  way in this white outfit  [Music]  uh  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  uh  [Music]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  how amazing are they i believe they  formed in 1987 michael they've been at  the luxor since 2015. that's what you  call talent and longevity yeah speaking